[Music]
happy birthday
[Music]
Billy eilish celebrates her 21st
birthday with a Holly Jolly Christmas
themed bash which is so incredible and
it was so amazing the Songbird partied
the night away on Saturday with a bunch
of her famous friends including her
boyfriend Jesse Rutherford yeah that's
Billy laying a big kiss on her man
dressed in a red velvet mini dress with
white trim yeah amazing Lil Nas X was at
the bash rocking a torso bearing
Ensemble and clearly having a blast with
Avril Lavigne Eric Andre Noah Cyrus and
Dove Cameron oh yeah I have like content
on content on content also in attendance
Kendall Jenner Haley and Justin Bieber
Haley Steinfeld Aza Gonzalez and Skyler
Aston
foreign
[Music]
and check out that over-the-top
two-tiered candy cane cake
[Music]
Billy's big birthday bash came just one
day after she performed at a sold-out
show in Los Angeles where her boyfriend
surprised her with a birthday cake on
stage to celebrate the special occasion
it's like so flattering of course it's
been an awesome year for Billy this is a
song that I genuinely like adore to be
honest I love this song we created I
feel really proud of it and
I love to perform it in March Billy and
her brother Phineas took home the Oscar
for best original song at the 94th
Academy Awards for their James Bond
theme no time to die
in April Billy headlined Coachella then
in July the Grammy winner released two
surprise tracks TV and the 30th
it looks so pretty but it wasn't all
work and no play for Billy this year the
singer went official with Jesse on
Instagram the day after Halloween
seemingly poking fun at their 11-year
age Gap Billy dressed up as a baby and
Jesse as an old man and the next month
the two made their red carpet debut
Rocky and Gucci pajamas to the 11th
annual LACMA art and film Gala in
November
she recently opened up about her love
during a chat with Vanity Fair
really cool and I'm really excited and
I'm really happy about it can we just
run of Applause for me
thank you
Jesse run the route everyone
I pulled his all me I did that I locked
that [ __ ] down well Billy
clearly thinks Jesse is a hottie she
says their love is deeper than what's on
the surface I just I'm really inspired
by this person and
you know he's inspired by me it's really
cool from Big Milestones to love one
thing's for sure Billy is ready for a
great year
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]